- Le réveil a été chaotique
pour de nombreux Canadiens.
Privés de leur connexion
Internet en raison d'une panne
majeure du réseau de Rogers
Communications à travers
le pays, faire preuve
de débrouillardise
pour commencer leur journée.
dans un café pour travailler,
mais là non plus, pas
de connection Internet.a peut-êe
de congé. Je suis certain
clients essaient
de me joindre, mais qu'ils n'y
arrivent pas. Ça m'inquiète
Vers 9 heures, Rogers a annoncé
une pas réseaux
filaire et sans-fil.
L'entreprise dit travaillerr rér
les services le plus rapidement
possible, sans tou, sans tou, sr
plus de détails.consultant
en cybersécurité, Trilogiam
- Historon voit,
dans des pannes comme ça
dans ces grosses compagnies
de télécur de configuration
d'équipement ou un équipement...
un bris d'équipement quelconque.
Moi, je mettrais ma main
dans le feu feu que c'est plus
- De nombreux services
ont été affectés par la pann
Des plateformes de paiement
ont par exemple été mises hors
service. À certains endroi
par carte de débit ou de crédit.
Des services de police
de la région de Toronto,
d'Edmonton et de Winnipeg ont
quant à eux averti les personnes
abonnées à Roger
de contacter le 911
en cas d'urgence.
de Service Canada qui eux aussi
ont été touchés, n
le service des passeports.
"C'est ce qui arril
n'y a que quelques fournisseurs
d'Internet. Tout le pays est
touché", lance ce
Cette panne majeure,
la deuxième en 14 mois
pour Rogers, survient
alors que l'entreprise souha
Shaw Communications.
Le projet inquiète notamment
le Bureau de la co
réduirait le choix pour
les Canadiens et eit
des facteurs.
- Est-cerrait avoir
plus de compétition,
plus de redondance? Peut-être.
st des événements
comme ça qui vont orte
que peut-être on se requestionne
sur nos télécommunications.
- Difficile pour l'instant
d'évaluer l'impaquequequequequee
de la panne. Une chose est sûre
: elle causera bien des maux
de tête, surtout.
la dernière", croit-il.
Il recommande aux Canadiens
et aux entreprises de mieux
se préparer, notamment
en s'assurant de toujours avoir
à leur disposition.
Ici Andréane Will